bienvenidos a la entrevista soy maría
jara calle los países de américa logran
cada vez más alianzas para proteger los
océanos de hecho cuatro naciones de la
región pactaron un corredor marino que
se convertirá en el área marina
protegida más grande del hemisferio
occidental los países que lo hicieron
fueron costa rica panamá ecuador y
colombia para hablar del tema hoy
estamos con carlos correa el ministro de
ambiente y desarrollo sostenible de
colombia señor correa bienvenido a
france 24 un placer tenerlo aquí con
nosotros en la cumbre de las américas
que se realizó a principios de junio en
la ciudad estadounidense de los ángeles
ocurrieron varios avances para la
protección de los océanos los cuatro
países que ya mencioné firmaron el
memorándum para crear el corredor marino
del pacífico este tropical cuéntenos
cuál es la importancia de ese corredor y
concretamente que está haciendo colombia
para la conservación de esa zona y sobre
todo para financiarlas bueno muchas
gracias maría tara primero cabe anotar
que esto inicia en el año 2020 cuando
colombia firma en el marco de una gran
alianza global el high and vision
coalición y es proteger el 30 ciento de
las áreas marinas y terrestres antes del
año 2030 y esto hace parte precisamente
de esa gran alianza una alianza que
viene con una iniciativa importante de
francia del reino unido y de costa rica
y que 90 países firman y colombia se
parte de esto en el marco de eso venimos
ampliando nuestro territorio en nuestras
áreas marinas y terrestres y este es uno
de esos corredores tan importantes que
pone de acuerdo a cuatro países
alrededor de la conservación y ese
corredor del pacífico está ecuador desde
la isla galápagos malpelo yurupary en
colombia la cohiba en panamá e isla el
coco en costa rica y con esto se
consolida un corredor marino muy
importante con una biodiversidad
increíble y ahora lo importante no es
solamente estas declaratorias que
estamos haciendo sino precisamente la
gestión de esas áreas en los próximos
años y para eso hay recursos de
cooperación internacional y que cada uno
de los países se han comprometido a
gestionar entonces hoy podemos ver como
cuatro países se unen alrededor de la
conservación de la conservación marina
colombia avanza en la declaratoria de
ese 30% que se ha comprometido a hacerlo
8 años antes o sea en julio del 2022
colombia tendrá la declaratoria del 30
por ciento de sus áreas marinas y
terrestres y colombia tiene dos océanos
así que no solamente el pacífico sino
también en el caribe estamos trabajando
y esa financiación y esa cooperación
internacional de la que nos habla 4
dinero tiene bueno esa es una muy buena
pregunta porque hoy hemos diseñado en
colombia un instrumento herencia
colombia y precisamente ese instrumento
lo que busca es la financiación los 10
primeros años de nuestras áreas
protegidas de ese 30 por ciento 100
millones de dólares a través de más de
30 donantes internacionales y 100
millones de dólares que pone el gobierno
nacional 200 millones de dólares para
gestionar esas áreas protegidas de
colombia en los próximos 10 años y por
supuesto los corredores marinos como el
corredor del pacífico hacen parte de
esta protección y de esta gestión de
áreas otro de los grandes temas de la
cumbre de las américas fue la coalición
américas por la protección del océano
chile y que busca proteger o conservar
al menos el 30% del océano pacifico para
2030 lo que se relaciona con el programa
del que ustedes ya nos habló explíquenos
qué acciones concretas dejará atrasadas
este gobierno que ya sale para alcanzar
el objetivo bueno colombia sigue
comprometido y el llamado de colombia es
a la acción a que podamos hacer este
tipo de iniciativas 8 años antes que
podemos hacerlo y por supuesto esto que
firmamos en la cumbre de las américas
hace unos días él juega un papel
importante ya veníamos trabajando en el
30-30 que es el high and vision
coalición y ahora con esta iniciativa
importante de toda américa creo que
damos un paso adelante en el compromiso
para que todos los países hagan lo que
venimos haciendo con iniciativas como la
del corredor del pacífico también en el
atlántico en el caribe estamos
trabajando con iniciativas importantes
por ejemplo con república dominicana que
también estuvo en la cumbre de las
américas y que venimos trabajando para
poder proteger un área en el caribe que
une a las dos naciones entonces mira
como las iniciativas de un corredor en
el pacífico y nos comienzan también a
dar pasos gigantes en el caribe
colombiano y creo que si hay algo que
nos una
es el medio ambiente la conservación que
una de los países que una a toda la
humanidad y esto es un claro ejemplo de
lo que estamos haciendo así que esta
iniciativa de la cumbre de las américas
hoy nos lleva a dar un paso adelante
sobre esta gran coalición global que se
viene trabajando a pesar de esa
coalición global y de las iniciativas de
la que usted nos habla hay unas brechas
por llenar y es que en 2010 los países
se comprometieron con las conocidas
metas de haití para proteger la
biodiversidad una de las metas era que
para 2020 el 17 por ciento de las zonas
terrestres y de las aguas continentales
del mundo estarían protegidas al igual
que el 10 por ciento de mares y océanos
pero colombia todavía está lejos de esa
cifra pues sólo el 8 por ciento de su
superficie marina está protegida según
el sistema de información ambiental de
colombia porque el país no ha cumplido
con la meta a haití y como cerrar esa
brecha
en maría clara colombia ha cumplido y
está cumpliendo hoy colombia tiene el
13.5 por ciento de áreas marinas
protegidas y un 16.5 por ciento de áreas
terrestres protegidas y lo que estamos
haciendo con esta declaratoria en estos
próximos días donde quedará ya en firme
es vamos a duplicar las áreas o sea
estaremos quedando con más de un 32% de
áreas marinas protegidas y un 30% de
áreas terrestres protegidas a través de
mecanismos importantes como homex otros
mecanismos de conservación y también de
zonas importantes que van a ser know
takes zonas de no pesca donde vamos a
poder tener una protección muchísimo
mayor así como por ejemplo la tenemos en
el santuario de flora y fauna de malpelo
pero colombia hoy tiene el 13.5 por
ciento y el 16.5 que entre las dos suman
un 15% de áreas protegidas y ahora
seguiremos avanzando y diciéndole a la
humanidad a los países a los gobiernos
que tenemos un gran compra de hacer esto
no al año 2030 sino 8 años antes y que
el llamado es a la acción ministro usted
habla del 13 por ciento de superficie
marina protegida y como le dije el
sistema de información ambiental habla
del 8 por ciento a qué se debe esta
diferencia de los porcentajes yo creo
que hay varios temas por uno de ellos se
registró la forma de registrar en los
sistemas siempre va un poco retrasada
hoy vamos en un nivel
de registro muy importante lo hacemos
prácticamente mensualmente en la medida
en que vamos haciendo áreas protegidas
pero colombia está cumpliendo con esas
metas y no solamente está cumpliendo
sino que las va a duplicar 8 años antes
de lo establecido en esta gran coalición
global del 30 30 usted habla de duplicar
este porcentaje de zonas protegidas y
llegar a más del 30 por ciento para
cuando se va a hacer esto porque usted
nos dice 8 años antes es decir que el
término sería prácticamente en un mes es
posible lograr esto en un mes madre
clara en un mes colombia tendrá el 30
por ciento de áreas marinas terrestres
protegidas ya estaremos en unos días en
lisboa en esa cumbre de océanos de las
naciones unidas y ahí estaremos haciendo
anuncios muy importantes
uno de ellos por supuesto será en
materia de océanos que es esta gran
cumbre y así como lo ha dicho en un mes
colombia estará contándole al planeta
que ha llegado al 30 por ciento de sus
áreas marinas y terrestres algún
adelanto de cómo vamos a lograr ese
porcentaje bueno venimos trabajando este
fue un compromiso que hicimos en la cob
26 en glasgow el presidente duque
una vez lanzamos toda la estrategia de
carbono neutralidad del país la
estrategia de cómo íbamos a reducir las
emisiones en un 51 por ciento al año
2030 y de cómo íbamos a proteger el 30
por ciento de nuestro territorio ese
gran anuncio y es que colombia se
comprometía al 2022 a hacer el 30 por
ciento de áreas marinas y terrestres
protegidas a declararlas y llevamos ocho
meses trabajando de la mano de los
cooperantes de las diferentes ongs de
las comunas por supuesto de las
entidades públicas para poder hacer esto
es una cantidad de información hemos
hecho inversiones de más de 7 millones
de dólares en menos de ocho meses para
tres expediciones marinas en el caribe
en el pacifico que nos permitieran tener
toda la información y poder hacer la
justificación ante la academia de
ciencias naturales que es uno de los
pasos que tiene colombia es diferente a
otros países pero hoy la academia de
ciencia está trabajando en esto por eso
digo que en un mes y la academia ha
estado revisando toda la información que
hoy tenemos para poder en darnos por
supuesto ese voto de confianza además de
que es muy importante tener ya la
financiación de la gestión de esas áreas
por los próximos diez años y el medio
ambiente hay un término que es carbono
azul se les dice así a las zonas marinas
costeras que absorben gran parte del
carbono que hay en la atmósfera y que
incluyen por ejemplo las praderas
marinas en las marismas y los manglares
importancias altísimo porque ayudan a
mitigar la crisis climática y colombia
tiene más de 285.000
de manglares en el pacífico y en el
litoral caribe lo que lo convierte en el
cuarto país con la mayor extensión de
este ecosistema en nuestra región pero
los están talando ministro sobre todo
por infraestructura como el país está
combatiendo esto bueno aquí hay un tema
muy importante y si hay algo que
colombia ha trabajado y sobre todo en
este gobierno del presidente de duke es
poner en el centro de la agenda el medio
ambiente la sostenibilidad de la
conservación y una de esas luchas que
tenemos en la lucha contra la
deforestación no solamente del bosque el
52% de colombia está cubierto por bosque
tenemos el 34 por ciento de nuestro
territorio en la amazonía sino también
esos manglares a los que te refieres y
ahí viene ese concepto de carbono azul
hay un manglar puede capturar 10 veces
más que un árbol entonces ahí viene la
importancia de proteger los manglares
hoy protegen las costas erosión costera
y al mismo tiempo con la captura podemos
tener a las comunidades trabajando en
esa conservación para poder tener
ingresos a través de transacciones
importantes en el mercado internacional
eso es el famoso carbono azul el carbono
que captura el manglar y ahí venimos
trabajando el primer proyecto
certificado a nivel mundial por ver está
en la bahía de cispatá en colombia 9 mil
800 hectáreas y con eso ya hoy las
comunidades están recibiendo ingresos
para poder seguir conservando así que
lucha contra la deforestación y también
al mismo tiempo el trabajo con las
comunidades sobre todo en las costas
colombianas para poder hacer proyectos
de carbono azul y no quiero terminar
esta entrevista sin antes preguntarle
por las aguas internacionales que son el
gran vacío pues a pesar de que ocupan un
64% de los océanos sólo el 1% está
protegido según el programa de la onu
para el medio ambiente que se ha hecho
en américa latina y el caribe y en
colombia para resguardar las aguas
internacionales y por qué es tan difícil
lograr acuerdos al respecto bueno creo
que siempre históricamente esto ha sido
un tema de límites y creo que hoy el
medio ambiente comienza a borrar esas
líneas y esos límites y el claro ejemplo
de lo que estamos haciendo en
latinoamérica y el caribe es el corredor
del pacífico que será un ejemplo no
solamente para la región sino a nivel
mundial de 4 como 4 países colombia
ecuador costa rica y panamá se unen
alrededor de la conservación de la
protección de un corredor marino que une
estas fronteras y que nos va a permitir
proteger la biodiversidad al mismo
tiempo estamos trabajando en el caribe
venimos haciendo avances con el gobierno
de república dominicana
conversaciones con jamaica con cada uno
de los países que entre todos podemos
lograr también corredores importantes
entonces este hito tan importante como
es el corredor del pacífico será un
legado para que los demás países no
solamente de la región sino del mundo se
unan alrededor de la protección de esas
aguas internacionales que tanto
necesitamos carlos eduardo correa
ministro ambiente de colombia gracias
por estar con nosotros aquí en france 24
muchísimas gracias y ustedes sigan con
nosotros para más información
internacional
[Música]